hello everyone my name is suam uh thank
you so much for being part of this
session I hope you're having a great
time at the conference in this session
we'll look at the ecoflow package it's
just a project name for the prefect
workflows for scaling acostic fishery
survey
pipelines it's a package developed using
prefect orchestration tool which can
streamline the processing of Sona data
now while this package is tailored for
Sona data processing the architecture
itself is very flexible and thus the
package can be extended Beyond sonar
data to accommodate other data types and
processing apis for example um you can
use this package to orchestrate some
Python scripts which are dealing with
geospatial data or even relational data
so this session is definitely useful for
data as well as software Engineers who
are interested in parallel data
processing or want to implement Dynamic
workflows using standard Python and
seeking functionality like uh scheduling
or a workflow kind of a tool and if
you're a researcher or someone actively
involved in sonar data or AC costic data
this session is just tailored for you
we'll explore how eflow can be a
GameChanger in your work and provide
solutions to the current challenges that
uh this industry is
facing it was Don uh San who one of my
colleagues who started this project and
I would like to thank him for laying a
solid foundation and supporting me
throughout I worked on this project as
part of my internship at the Ean
Institute which is here in Seattle I
would like I would also like to
acknowledge um Valentina and wuang for
their continuous support and for giving
me this
opportunity okay before getting into the
project here's a very brief beef
background about me as uh oneone already
introduced me I'm currently pursuing my
master's degree in data science at the
University of Washington I have three
year three and a half years of
experience as a software and data
engineer I worked at deoy and
misisco and of course I have uh gained a
lot of different expertise in various
aspects like application development
cyber security and more recently data
pipelines currently I'm working with AWS
as part of my capson project to address
shortcomings in current commodity
Hardware testing methods I'm trying to
enhance the decision making behind
onboarding new hard drives in S3 the end
result would help AWS in optimizing S3's
storage and
performance and of course I'm interning
at escience Institute for this project
and working towards adding more
capabilities to this package something
like realtime data processing and adding
more deployment options in
future all right moving on um here is
what we have on the agenda for this
session we'll kick off the session by
addressing the two most important
questions that is why we need this and
where is where can this be used
basically we'll try to understand the
purpose of this package I will also give
a brief background of sonar and acostic
data
processing following that we will quick
will see a quick comparison between
airflow and
prefect which should give some insights
into why we opted for prefect over a
popular tool like
airflow our journey continues with a
deep dive into echol flow's architecture
complemented by a live uh demo
showcasing its functionality and
development options deployment
options
finally uh is there a question
okay finally we'll look at some
solutions that echol flow offers for
common challenges in creating such
Dynamic data workflows and then we'll
open the floor for any
questions so without the further delay
let's see how eof flow can be a game
changer and streamline the data
processing echol flow offers many use
cases from oceanography studies to
identifying species and tracking their
behavior it can also be used in
monitoring fish population one of the
example could be NOA Fisheries group
with whom we collaborate since they lie
between
um fishery scientists and agencies and
data
scientists this project could be
particularly useful um to them since
they do something called as fishery
stock assessment for someone who doesn't
know what Noah is Noah is a national
ocean and Atmospheric
Administration it's a group which
continuously researches and does um
things related to Ocean and
Atmospheric lastly uh eof flow is
customizable so research groups can come
up with more processing stages tailored
to their unique
requirements and would still be able to
use this package this
adaptability also facilitates the
seamless switch between different data
types which I was talking earlier the
major reason is the absence of any
hardcoded constraints which helps echol
flow fit into almost every changing
need now we know the spectrum of use
cases that the echol flow package can
cater to let's have a look at what
exactly is sonar and acostic data
processing and why do we need it
echosounder is a basically a device as
you can see in the diagram it's attached
to a ship it uses sound waves to measure
the distance in the ocean or identify
objects
underwater this can give us some vital
insights into the underwater
environments over the years there have
been many ships and autonomous devices
autonomous devices are basically a
device without a humor intervention and
can either cover a specific area or be
Standalone in the seat
in order to collect sonar data this data
collection has been going on from years
now resulting in a very big data set
which is around 250
terabytes and since it has been going on
since uh many years and there have been
many tools which are used to record such
data there uh these tools are using
different encoding and due to that it
possesses a great uh challenge to
process process such data additionally
there might also be a need for different
workflows to process this data since
people might be interested in getting
different insights from the same data so
current tools are not capable of
handling such data and such workflows
thus we need a much better compute as
well as uh some tools which can
orchestrate
well within e Science Institute I'm
working with a group called ecospace
Group which focuses on Marine Science
and Technology and we as a group are
committed to developing an open-source
python software toolbox designed to
transform sunar data into valuable
insights so we are offering a a set of
packages basically which can help from
which can help end to end right from
processing a raw data to having
visualizations and machine
learning okay so now that we have our
why and where figured out let's delve
into Echo flow this diagram would be
able to give a better Clarity of what
exactly the role of echo flow is as you
can see the first step is to convert the
raw acostic data into a cloud optimized
data format something like a zar which
can be processed by echol flow we then
aggregate the process data into
manageable chunks followed by
calibration
uh which is addressing the variations in
the recording environment something that
we were talking in the previous slide
once we have the process data we can
extract the desired um features from it
this may involve Gathering biological
estimates and combining the ml
capabilities lastly to Showcase these
results we can also visualize them and
have interactive graphs for our better
understanding all of these steps are
handled by different packages which are
developed by our group crucially echol
flow serves as the orchestrator and
seamlessly manages and coordinates these
processes that is all the packages its
design not only streamlines the workflow
but also provides users with significant
flexibility in shaping their data
processing
Journey so we used prefect as the
backbone for echol flow which is a
hybrid orchestration tool offering both
a paid as well as open- Source version
it shares similarities with airflow
which is very popular tool for those
unfamiliar with both of them both are
basically tools which can be used to
orchestrate or basically manage the
execution of a data
Pipeline with prefect 2.0 it became very
easy to use it even for new users
because of its pythonic nature the ease
of integrating with standard python code
native support for distributed
processing libraries like dask and Ray
if you don't know what is distributed
processing lities we'll we'll delve into
that later because we are going to see a
demo as
well and thirdly the ability to create
Dynamic workflows that is allowing
flexibility in defining and modifying
the pipelines on the go these three
things were transformative to echol
flows development and certainly gave an
edge over airflow and thus we decided to
go with prefect rather than
airflow so talking about prefect uh
prefect uses two main Concepts that I
wanted to introduce that's flows and
tasks um so PIP plan is basically
logically uh separated into flow and
task a flow is a broader concept and can
have multiple task or subflows within it
so as we can see that flow one one has a
subflow uh which is
uh which is flow two and then we move on
to flow
three so and we have three tasks as well
tasks are discrete unit of
work which can perform some uh for
example API calling or uh some data
cleaning process or something like that
and these tasks can be of course reused
by flows which we can see that flow one
and two are sharing a task to so it also
allows uh reusing of tasks
basically okay let's take a closer look
at the prefect architecture to
understand it's working as echol flow
aligns with this model we have uh three
main blocks that is the prefect
Cloud uh there's a execution environment
which consists of an agent and the flow
code and then we have have various Cloud
Integrations as
well so code once orchestrated with
defect kicks off an agent there is
basically some Deployable which can take
the input and execute the pipeline
pipeline is nothing but the flow code
here when using prefect Cloud this agent
communicates with prefect API on the
cloud enabling centralized workflow
control whereas in offline scenarios um
we can spin up a FX server in our local
environment local environment is nothing
but our laptops or
desktops and the agent can communicate
with that
server there is also a component called
Cloud UI that interacts with
prefect and this Cloud UI or even in
local we have a UI this UI basically
provides us a dashboard to monitor all
the runs and scheduling
tasks and PR also seamlessly integrates
with a wide array of cloud platforms and
services and offers um multiple input
and output options along with we compute
sources um something like snowflake data
bre ews Azure gcp just to name a few
most popular ones which are used in uh
data pipelines or data
engineering now let's explore the
ecoflow architecture which Bears a lot
of resemblance to prefect as it serves
as the backbone of the package similar
to prefect air echol flow can connect to
most of the cloud Technologies spin up
an agent to execute the flows and
communicate with prefect API to have a
centralized
control eof flow takes uh raw files and
yaml configurations raw files are
nothing but the input files
here and the yaml configuration AIDS in
defining two key aspects I mean there
are two yaml files basically um one is
the data source yaml file which is
helping us specify the source
destination and how is the formatting of
the data the second is used to define
the execution order which is determining
which steps need to be executed and the
configuration for each
step I will go into much deeper into
these files when we go to the demo
section
coming to the echol flow architecture
like the code part itself some of the
components that echol flow has are
listed in the figure um as we can see
that there is Echo pipe Echo Shader Echo
regions and so on net CDF for Echo pipe
Checker all of these are modules that
are integrated with echol flow
and
uh we can also Define some custom
processing steps and simply add the
model modules to the AML configuration
these modules basically are nothing but
apis which help us process the data for
example echipe can be used to process
the raw data echos Shader provides us uh
with visualization capabilities and Echo
regions have the ml
libraries then we have uh libraries
which are marked in blue dask is one of
the library which which we are using for
distributed computing to execute bunch
of task on a cluster of
machine for logging users can either add
or extend a yaml configuration file
provided to log locally or they can also
use specific logging services or server
like uh AWS cloudwatch or
Splunk and finally we have some U
programming paradigms uh which are used
to make the work workflow simpler and
robust aop is one of them which is
aspect oriented programming it is use it
is useful to log or have flow
validations and having a centralized
error handling
basically for those unfamiliar aop is a
programming Paradigm that helps in
executing some code before and after a
function basically it's like a wrap
around a function eflow also has rest
API support it uh so it can communicate
with the restapi endpoints provided by
prefect and extract pipeline execution
metadata prefect
1.0 was using um graphql but from pect
2.0 they're using rest API so we have
the rest API support as
well eof flow also incorporates a basic
rule engine to ensure that while we
provide
flexibility we don't allow the execution
of invalid flows although we aim to give
users full contr control over what they
want to execute the rule engine helps to
Define some structure or order to the
execution okay last section before we
start the demo let's have a look at the
deployment options that we have echol
flow can be effortlessly deployed on
various platforms whether it's a virtual
machine something like cloud or local
machines or even with docu
containers in prefect there's a concept
of blocks I'll go into uh depth when we
go into the demo section blocks makes
the deployment very easy we can create a
storage block to store our code or exe
environment variables and execute this
uh storage block using an
infrastructured blog so infrastructure
block is nothing but for example a E2
instance for example which can help you
execute your storage block
and setting up the environment is also a
straightforward process but since the
package is still in its early stages you
need to clone the repo and install the
necessary dependencies within a virtual
environment once the environment and
repository are set up the next step
involves configuring two yaml files
which I was discussing earlier which
will help you to one file will deter
help you determine uh source and
destination of the data one will
determine uh what steps you need to
perform on that data
with these configurations in place we
can harness the CLI capabilities that is
command line interface capabilities
offered by echol flow that is we are
offering some um commands basically
which help you set up the uh the project
in your system and also help you um
configure your credentials for example
AWS credentials if you want to set up a
ec2 and you want to have credentials
locally so echol flows commands can be
used to set up these credentials as
well this enables us to create a working
directory and set up prefect profiles as
well
seamlessly the versatility of echol flow
inherited from prefect allows us to
choose between running the flows locally
by initializing prefect server or you
can utilize a prefect cloud account for
more um extensive tasks on the similar
lines um we can then opt for local
Computing or cloud computing something
like again EC to but we can also deploy
it as a systemd process systemd is
basically it allows echol flow to run as
a background service essentially your
ec2 will act as a computer server and it
will take all the flows from a work pool
and execute them whenever we want to
schedule
something okay let's go
to
the demo
section so I have already uh cloned the
repo and I also have set up the
environment what we can do is we can run
the
command uh Echo flow inite
and this will basically create
uh so yeah uh it will basically create
some folder structure internally
for in order to store some Json metad
data inside and this will be used while
processing I'll go to the Test Section
we have two notebooks here one is the
local notebook and but there is also ews
example which is so I'm starting from
how to clone the repo how to U make
the environment and then how to
initialize prefect how to initialize
ecoflow how to create a three bracket
store your credential and and I've
written everything in detail in that
notebook so you can also check out this
notebook I've added the GitHub Link in
the resource section of this
meet going to the offline
section uh so we have already done
installation and environment we also did
uh Echo flow in which is initialization
of echo flow I also have uh the prefect
profile created already so I'm just
going to start the prefect server here
so
prect server
start and this will start a server
locally which is at Port
42 then we'll load two uh yaml
configuration
files the first one
is so what we are doing here is we are
trying to calculate the target strength
from the raw files so we have two stages
one is open Draw and the second one is
Computing the target strength for this
we are using a active recipe name that
is that should match with this
uh Target strength recipe name so the
logic behind this is that we can have
multiple recipes in the same yaml file
but we can configure active recipe and
then just use that recipe for that for
that specific run I'm I'm going to use a
local dask here so if if I set it to
true it basically means that it will
internally create a DK
cluster and uh number of workers is five
so it will create five number of
workers and then this is just uh
specifying which module that I want to
execute and then we have some options
that is whether we want to use it use
the offline version I mean use the
offline files available do we want to
save the offline files uh like when we
fetch the raw files from uh from The
Source but we want to save them and then
we have similar for compute
TS
the uh there are also other options
available and you can go to the
documentation
uh
okay uh you can go to the pipeline
documentation
okay
[Music]
uh yeah here so you can see that there
are multiple options which you can
configure for each
uh
um basically a stage and then you can
have prefect configurations as well you
can specify the number of retries that
you want
Etc and you also have
uh
uh there's some
glitch and then you have this data
stored config yaml file so this is
basically used to mention your Source
this is the S3 URL that I'm going to use
Bas and
it will fetch all the raw files which
matches this regex and this is the ship
name survey name and so on model that
I'm so our model that I'm going to use
to fetch the data and we're also
defining some
transact since this is just a test I'm
going to uh pass on that uh all the
files belong to a same group transact is
basically a group and here's the output
uh folder that I'm going to use and I'm
going to say that okay we want to retain
the output and if if the destination
already has the output we are going to
override the output which is basically
override is equal to
True okay so let's fetch all the files
from here here we are just fetching the
name of the files we're not actually
fetching all the raw files from the S3
bucket here uh I'm just going to go 10
because 100 will take a little more time
than we have right now
and so this basically created a text
file here with 10 names of files which
we want to Pro process and I'm going to
pass those that uh file as an
input to our function and as we can see
this uh folder has been
created I can show maybe
your so as we can see that
uh raw files are downloaded and Zar
files are created from
that so it took about 25 seconds to
execute uh around 300 MB of
data and as you can see the D cluster
which I was talking about uh it
basically divides your processor I mean
the local computer into some number of
clusters there's one master cluster as
Master node as well and we had five
clusters to process this and we can see
that all 10 of them are
done
okay
um let's see the dashboard as well once
um of how it
looks so this is how the dashboard looks
like um when you execute some flows it
should come in the flow runs it should
display uh if there are any failures if
there are any success and what flows
that you have you can also create some
deployments um something like I have
created here you can see easy to and ECS
deployment then we have something called
as work pools which is basically when
you schedule a flow uh a uh a new job is
created in the work pool from that work
pool your E2 instance or wherever the
agent is that picks up your task and
this is what I was talking about the
blocks you can configure your
credentials here you can just click plus
and go on and have your AWS credentials
setup which can be used to uh basically
execute your flows on
AWS and yeah that's about it for this
session I hope you enjoyed the session